we are going to talk um to the
conservative chairs who's just come in
just as we're looking at those pictures
of the Prime Minister welcome to you
good morning to you well I say good
morning but give us an assessment of how
your party's been doing in these local
elections so far it's been a pretty
pretty brutal night for the
conservatives hasn't it well we all said
it would be a disappointing uh night
disappointing day yesterday uh for the
party uh the independent academic
forecasts were coming in that we were
going to lose a thousand seats obviously
only a quarter of seats have counted so
far and we've lost uh well-run
conservative councils and good
conservative councilors so clearly
overall it's been a disappointing night
well yes and you say disappointing night
but Midway Council in Gillingham that
has gone from the conservatives who've
held it for 20 years to labor that's
something that even Tony Blair didn't
manage it's a huge loss for you today
isn't it uh well look I mean there's
areas of course who were disappointed I
was in Medway during the course of the
campaign
um but you know equally there are areas
that labor need to win to show that
they're making progress and I don't
think they are making the comprehensive
progress that they need to make for
example exactly a place that like that a
conservative Heartland is
the conservatives have been gaining
seats in place of that Peterborough uh
in places like Sandwell in place like
Bassett Law you know those are all seats
that Jeremy corbyn won in 2017 that the
conservatives are gaining in uh this
year which I think means that for secure
starma it's not overall it's not a
uniformly good picture for labor in all
my conversations up and down the country
I have yet to meet a voter who comes to
the door enthusiastic about uh sirma and
his leadership of Labor whereas every
single conversation I've had is always
improved by the mention of Rishi sunak
and the job that he is doing in
difficult circumstances as prime
minister why then are you talking about
potentially losing a thousand seeds it's
something you said in the run-up to this
election repeatedly a lot of people
thought that was expectation management
but that does look like it's a real
possibility to be clear the thousand
seats is what the independent academic
forecasts are saying uh the professors
rallings Thrasher John Curtis are saying
the 1000. uh we'll have to wait and see
clearly it's a disappointing time
overall for the conservatives but I'm
quite clear this is not the sort of
euphoric labor win that they got in 1995
in advance you mentioned Tony Blair but
the year before Tony Blair's win labor
gained 1 661 seats the conservatives
lost more than 1 900 seats I don't think
we're seeing anything like that from
yesterday's results okay and you're
losing around one in three C's that you
were trying to defend so far you're
losing in all parts of the country as
well if that was to be replicated at a
general election Rishi sunak would be
out at number 10 wouldn't it well we'll
have to wait and see you know obviously
the seats that were up yesterday there
are more concern Innovative seats than
there were for labor and the lib Dems
combined so clearly the conservatives
had more to lose yesterday but in some
parts of the country which labor need to
show progress in and Harlow which was a
labor suit to 2010. the conservatives
gained seats in Harlow we gained seats
in Basset law we gained seats in
Sandwell which is West Bromwich we
gained seats in Peterborough you know
this is not a uniformly good picture of
a labor well no but let's look at the
conservatives you're defending from a
very poor Baseline at the last time
these seats were contested was 2019 and
it was the worst election results in
nearly a quarter of a century then and
if you look at the places so far that
you're losing and labor are winning
Stoke Plymouth Tamworth pretty crucial
general election
Battlegrounds aren't there they're
places that decide election well let's
be clear I mean in Plymouth there have
been a number of local factors involved
with the councilor uh winning back Stoke
and we've got a brilliant uh
conservative Council group led by Abby
Brown there but winning back Stoke is a
pretty low bar for labor under Jeremy
corbyn in 27 17 labor won two of the
three parliamentary seats in Stoke you
know this is not if you like a
conservative Heartland Stoke it's an
area we've done well in recently but
that sets a low bar for labor looking at
some of the areas that labor the labor
need to win like for example in Basset
law in Sandwell in Peterborough you know
the conservatives have actually been
gaining seats in those councils of
course it's overall a disappointing
night for us but we have seen areas
where labor need to make gains and they
haven't we've actually made gains okay
you mentioned Stoke there is also a
labor mayor now in Middlesbrough is this
a sign that the the red wall that Boris
Johnson smashed through is being rebuilt
well look we've all said it was going to
be a difficult night and it is a
difficult night in in some places but
what we're not seeing is labor making
that comprehensive breakthrough for
example just by t-side Hartlepool uh
remains a no overall control Council
that was you know Peter mandelson's
Parliament entry seat for many years you
know that is something that that labor
need to be winning but thanks to our
excellent local MP drill mortar were
holding on in Hartlepool as a no overall
control Council you know that is
somewhere where labor need to be
smashing it frankly so there are some
signs here that KIA storm is not getting
the cut through the Breakthrough that
labor needs uh
does there seem to be a springing back
of support for labor in areas that voted
brexit and where Boris Johnson did well
in 2019 it was always thought of the
time they maybe borrowed votes do you
think that's turning out to be the case
well look uh we'll have to wait and see
we're only one quarter of the way
through the results what I'm saying is
of course and we're very disappointed to
have made losses last night good
conservative councilors have lost their
seats but I'm not seeing that
breakthrough for labor that they would
need to be for securma to be able to say
hand on heart that he is ready to form a
government you know I don't think that
labor are doing well enough and as I say
we're actually seeing conservative gains
in places like Peterborough and Sandwell
and Basset law and other kind of key
places that in those most of those
places also voted for brexit will you
talk about key places what about losing
to the liberal Democrats you're losing
seats in in Windsor and maidenhead for
example well we're disappointed with the
results in uh Windsor and maidenhead and
Johnson there has run a good
conservative Council he and his team so
he's one of many people who who have had
disappointing nights as part of the
disappointment overall for the party but
again you know these are not a
comprehensive situation in 1995 before
Tony Blair's Landslide you know labor
were gaining 1900 seats sorry the 1 600
seats the conservatives lost 1 900 seats
I don't think we're seeing anything like
that how damaging has this last year
been to your party we're on the third
prime minister just in the last year
we've seen mortgage rates shoot up as a
result of Tory policies we've seen the
biggest set of public sector strikes in
decades and we've seen the tax burden at
its highest level for 70 years I mean
that's a pretty tough sell for voters as
well I think the country has had a
difficult year the conservative party
has had a difficult year a lot of that
is driven of course by Vladimir Putin's
invasion of Ukraine the big spike in
Energy prices the big spiky inflation
but that is exactly why Rishi sunak has
given the priority he's been given to
halving inflation cutting the debt
growing the economy reducing hospital
waitingness and stopping the boats that
is those are the government's priorities
those I think are the people's
priorities moving forward I Think We're
British internet will be getting on with
the job with the whole cabinet making
sure we continue to deliver for the
whole country so but overall a
disappointing night for the time overall
of course it's a disappointing night and
we've lost some good counselors and
there'll be a number of people feeling
quite sore this morning people I know
well having been in the conservative
party for the last 37 years I know many
of our councilors personally who've had
reverses last night but I do say quite
clearly that this is not a comprehensive
picture for labor Under kirst Armor
there's places there that Jeremy corbyn
won in 2017 like for example
Peterborough Sandwell Basset law the
labor that the conservatives have been
gaining seats last night so this is not
a uniformly good picture for late okay
well we appreciate you coming in and
checking in at this stage of the account
thanks very much indeed